laurent et bien on se retrouve dans
quelques instants il est maintenant 7h30
à la pendule de télématin et voici la
deuxième édition du journal tout de
suite avec claire chazal
situation encore très tendue en roumanie
des affrontements ont eu lieu cette nuit
à bucarest
la fille de chez oc secousse hoya a été
arrêté coup de théâtre au panama le
général noriega s'est rendu à
l'ambassade du vatican à panama city
pour y demander l'asile politique
bonjour à bucarest en roumanie une nuit
de noël faite d'espoir mais aussi de
très grande tension
des affrontements ont encore eu lieu
autour des bâtiments de la télévision et
de la radio et une vingtaine de membres
de la securitate et ont tenté de
s'emparer de la gare centrale de
bucarest
yann lavoix